avec nous pour décortiquer ces annonces
pierre andré bouchard saint-amand qui
est économiste professeur en finances
publiques à l'ena bonsoir et olivier
jacques professeur en politique publique
à l'école de santé publique de
l'université montréal bonsoir
j'ai le goût d'entendre vos premières
réactions parce que les milliards
pleuvent aujourd'hui au québec de toute
évidence on est comme dans une
surenchère de baisses d'impôts et de
baisses de taxes olivier jacque d'abord
mais ce que j'ai l'impression que le
gouvernement fait aujourd'hui c'est
qu'ils proposent une baisse d'impôt pour
plaire aux électeurs à court terme yvon
la financer en faisant payer les
générations futures ce qu'est ce que ça
fait là la baisse des versements au
fonds des générations ainsi que ça va
augmenter la dette publique il s'avoue
réduire la marge de manoeuvre fiscale du
gouvernement à l'avenir bon parfum de
pierre andré bouchard maintenant c'est
toujours une chorale très certainement
on annoncé des montants importants
lorsqu'on modifie le régime fiscal on
essaie toujours d'arbitrer entre
l'efficacité économique la réduction des
inégalités que ce soit de immédiate ou
de long terme on a aujourd'hui 2
deux partis politiques qui ont choisit
l'efficacité au détriment des deux
autres dimensions c'est un choix
politique mais nous avons la capacité de
faire ça financière on a une capacité de
court terme c'est à dire que on a une
marge de manoeuvre qui s'est dégagé
notamment avec les pressions salariales
l'augmentation des recettes fiscales on
a un gouvernement qui va bientôt faire
face à des négociations de conventions
collectives aussi donc il cherche pas
vraiment à contrôler ses revenus ceci
dit si on se projette sur 20 ou 25 ans
ou y voir une croissance importante des
dépenses de santé on risque de remettre
en question disons des baisses d'impôts
tel qu'on est en train de voir et quand
vous dites les prochaines générations
vont payer c'est que on ampute des
revenus de façon permanente quand on
réduit les paliers d'impôts mais aussi
le fonds des générations génère du
rendement est donc une partie du
rendement que nous toucherons pas exact
si c'est 10 milliards de dollars qui
sont perdus il pourrait revenir sur la
question de la hausse des dépenses de
santé à moyen terme mais on a beaucoup
de défis auxquels on fait face au québec
lance moment les filets la situation des
finances publiques est bonne mais va
falloir payer pour des dépenses de santé
qui vont être plus cher à cause du
vieillissement de la population à cause
d'une inflation des coûts est aussi va
falloir payer pour les défis
environnementaux qui nous attendent donc
la situation des finances publiques au
québec à moyen terme est beaucoup plus
difficile qu'est ce qu'on voit
actuellement oui le rapport pré
électorale nous laisser l'impression que
les choses allaient terriblement bien
est ce que l'objectif et des libéraux et
de la caq ici c'est quand même d'aider
les familles à faire face à l'inflation
est-ce que de baisser les impôts de
baisser certaines taxes d'envoyer un
chèque en fin d'année comme le propose
la caq pire andré bouchard saint-amand
ça nous aide à faire face à l'inflation
très certainement ça va communiquer en
fait on redonne du revenu augmenter leur
revenu disponible oui de plusieurs
ménages ceci dit lorsqu'on augmente
aussi la capacité de dépenser des
ménages
on augmente en fait la demande pour
certains produits ce qui se traduit par
des hausses de prix alors on peut jouer
avec le régime fiscal tant et aussi
longtemps qu'on veut on n'augmente pas
le nombre de personnes qui sont aptes et
disponible aller travailler sur le
marché alors on change pas la mairie de
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre on change
pas le fait qu' un vieillissement de la
population donc les fondamentaux qui
peut me dire justement une augmentation
importante des prix une chance pour
entrave à cette vérification a octroyé 3
milliards 500 millions en décembre comme
ont octroyé 3 milliards 200 millions en
mai c'est inflationnistes c'est sûr que
ça stimule la dépense donc ça stimule
l'augmentation des prix à travers
justement
le plus important d'achats l'ennui c'est
qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de choses que
le gouvernement peut faire à court terme
pour régler les problèmes
inflationnistes et les gens ont besoin
d'être en ce moment et il est revenu de
l'étang aux crues c'est là que je pense
que l'échec ponctuelle elles sont
préférables aux baisses d'impôts parce
que les baisses d'impôts nuisent à la
capacité fiscale de l'état à moyen terme
l'échec bon c'est une fois on a des gens
qui en ont besoin en ce moment
l'inflation l'espère vont finir par
diminué donc baisses d'impôts une chose
l'échec deuxième chose les libéraux ont
quelques autres mesures notamment la
suspension des de la tvq sur les biens
de première nécessité et la suspension
de tvq sur les premiers 4000 $ de notre
facture d'électricité
ça je présume que ça touche davantage
les moins nantis de la société mais ça
touche les moyens de la société mais ça
coûte quand même cher à l'état et sa
main si c'est des dépenses publiques
qu'on peut pas qu'on peut pas faire il
les dépenses publiques de l'état sont
bénéfiques aux moins nantis aussi donc
je moi je suis pas nécessairement
convaincu que c'est une mesure qui est
soutenable à long terme et qui va aider
les moins nantis à long terme c'est sûr
qu'à court terme bon on rend les
produits moins chers et donc on les ied
dans cette logique lorsqu'on endosse
l'idylle qu'on veut soulager en
calculations éliminant de dépenses
importantes on aurait peut-être préféré
voir une augmentation du crédit de
solidarité de nature uniforme plutôt qu
une abolition des taxes sur des produits
ciblés on aurait pu le faire de manière
à ce que le montant sous équivalent mais
lorsqu'on change en quelque sorte les
prix relatifs entre les différentes
composantes de ce que peut acheter un
ménage on est entré aussi d'inciter
implicitement à acheter davantage ou
pour les entreprises qui vendent du
shampoing assefa passé quelque chose qui
n'est pas du shampoing pour du shampoing
pour une vie très attractif mais le
parti libéral propose oui je comprends
ce que voulait dire du parti libéral
propose de bonifier le crédit d'impôt
solidarité qui seraient alors moi j'ai
arrêté leur sait si j'avais pu dans les
pantalons qui décide au au parti
libéral-radical prenons la mesure de tvq
d'abolition mecs sont en train de faire
oublions ça et doublons en fait sur
l'idée de la bonification et le gel des
tarifs d'hydro-québec est ce que c'est
une mesure qui était pas brillé qui va
aider les citoyens mais c'est sûr que ça
aide les citoyens comme voie court terme
mais ensuite on a des défis
environnementaux auxquels il faut faire
face et il faut pas consommer trop
d'électricité donc on en voit peut-être
pas nécessairement le bon message ici ce
qui est intéressant c'est que le
gouvernement du québec peut pas
facilement augmenter ses tarifs
d'hydroélectricité puisque s'il le fait
il va perdre les revenus de péréquation
donc c'est sûr qu'on n'a pas beaucoup
d'incitatifs avoir des tarifs
d'hydroélectricité plus élevé et on a vu
que ça a été un enjeu cette année avec
inflation assez élevé donc je comprends
pourquoi est ce que les partis bel album
dans cette direction là mais est-ce que
ça envoie le bon message d'économie
d'énergie qu'il faut pour mettre en
place dernier point sur le fonds des
générations est ce qu'on est ce que est
ce qu'on a raison
de requêtes thione le fonds des
générations parce que je regarde les
sommes qu'ils allaient être versés au
cours des prochaines années ne savait
que le fonds des générations il ya un
surplus il ya un versements au fonds des
générations qui ensuite en ce moment on
est en déficit parce qu'on met 3 4
milliards mais là dans un an deux
soeurettes rendre à 5 milliards par
année ça va quasiment rendu impossible
de faire du surplus budgétaires est-ce
qu'on a raison de re questionner les
versements au fonds des générations
je pense que les motifs qui ont mené le
fond dégénéré a sion l'existence de
fonds des générations sont toujours à
propos est tout à fait viable on devrait
continuer de financer ce projet le ya
personne qui remettent en question non
plus d'ailleurs c'est une question de
dosage
et ben je pense que de ce point de vue
là on est peut-être mieux de jouer du
côté prudent que du côté électoralistes
alors nous agirons qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec cet argent on pourrait se dire on
investit moins dans le fonds des
générations mais à la place on veut
investir dans des mesures qui vont nous
permettre de réduire la croissance des
coûts de la santé à moyen terme investir
dans des infrastructures vertes et
cetera mais là on parle de baisser les
impôts c'est pas une mesure qui va avoir
un effet très positif à long terme au
québec alors que le fonds des
générations effectivement que monsieur
saint-amand dit ben les défis sont
encore là les enjeux de finances
publiques sont encore là et on va avoir
besoin de l'utiliser à l'avenir bon
merci beaucoup pour cette analyse très
intéressante une journée forte déjà
aujourd'hui de la campagne électorale
jean jacques pierre andré bouchard
s'était merci merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]